well serious is that I didn't I didn't I
knew everybody
Nick least of all but I've made great
friends with Nick and Adam is the most
kind and generous and there isn't
Hollywood you are too Nana and they've
all been very kind to me and I think
well norm you are awesome we all know
him we all love you sometimes this is
the part of the part of the night or
usually happens about this time when the
medication goes off can I can I say
something sure do you remember how
exciting it was swore you weren't there
I'm sorry but you can jump in anyways
but when when when Conan got the show oh
yeah yeah how great that was when we
were all young boys at Saturday Night
Live Oh young sir know a lot guys and
you were the man and there was like a
big deal and they gave it a morning
generic I remember the very night
because we were in mall honking we was
right yeah right that's right we were
more walk with Farley
yeah and Farley was there Harley that
night is the first night I ever met
Farley was your first night on the show
we all sat around and watched it was all
right here on buddy and Farley he took
me he never met me before in his life
you know they took me back
he said I got to tell you a secret about
it out the hotel right hotel he secret
admitting liked it and he made sure
wasn't bugged and everything he said I
got a secret I was very you know honored
to have this and then his secret was he
said this doesn't go past these walls
Pat is a woman
[Applause]
you